it was a series of murders that would
defy human comprehension this is the
worst case of serial killing in
Australia's history the revelations
about the case would captivate and shock
the nation it's the stuff of horror
movies
torture electrocution decapitation and
at one stage cannibalism there's no
[Music]
third one in - hmm remember like we said
on the last episode that we were gonna
start doing the opening segment and the
news it's right video glorious that's
right video we're gonna do with Kailen
drinks yeah look at this cranberry it's
like the middle of the afternoon yeah I
just don't even know right you know
that's nice about working at home though
I can drink all right so 102 is about
what now snow town murders yes I'm sorry
I'm very sorry in advance but this is
like a very very depressing topic but it
has been requested many many times
probably one of the most infamous serial
killers in Australian history that's
right we had some requests for some
Australians though yes and I'm for some
reason I'm like kind of fascinated by
Australian crime and this and this one
this case is like pretty [ __ ] up
because not only was it like a serial
killer but also it was one of those
cases where it was a serial killer who
somehow convinced like a whole bunch of
other people to go along with it and you
know it was one of those kind of things
there's a bunch of accomplices yeah and
it went on for a long time like without
anybody knowing about it and it's like
it's just a horrible horrible case and
you know and the funny thing - well it's
not funny I'm just saying that like the
news stories - are also kind of
depressing yeah so I'm sorry to bum you
out you guys but that's just what's
that's what happened
this show that's what happens on 13
o'clock everyone gets bummed out and
drunk yeah right now I also want to make
an announcement
we're um we're gonna open up a third
channel we're working on some pilot
episodes right now yes and we're gonna
try them out on some of our subscribers
first yeah general public won't know
about it
we're gonna try to try them out on our
subscribers first on our patrons and our
patrons skin and we're gonna perfect it
before we open them before we drop them
on the public yeah the thing is though
is that in order to open a third channel
we're gonna have to it's gonna almost
become a full-time job to do this so we
we're gonna have to do this the way
other channels do it we're gonna go on
our patreon page and we're gonna change
the little [ __ ] up goal that we had to
a real goal if we can get a thousand
dollars a month in patrons we can make
this more of a full-time job by then
we'll have a better audio and visual
setup yeah and we'll be able to ship
some of our efforts away from graphic
design business into actual the show so
we're gonna set a new goal for 1,000
because I'm very excited about this
third show though we've been talking
about like I said I'm gonna say what it
is right it's gonna be another kind of
weekly show and it's gonna be like a
third like a supplement rights like our
movie super movie reviews are but you
know I don't want to tease it so so much
yet until it's totally finished and it
until it's a totally crystallized idea
but it's gonna be kind of nostalgic it's
gonna have a lot of humor and a lot of
information in it yeah I think you guys
are gonna like it
but we're gonna try it out on some of
our patrons first and once it's right
and we have a thousand dollars a month
in patreon money we can then open that
channel and we'll open that one up
probably where the goof for episodes
just right off the bat or at least four
episodes backed up yeah because there's
production
time problems involved I'm not gonna do
cuz we try to do a similar thing with
our 13 o'clock in minutes and yeah wrong
mate well I made like 10 or 11 of those
and like they came out cool but I think
a lot of the reason that a lot of people
like our show and like a lot of the
feedback that I got was that you like
our interaction and like nice
bullshitting about talking about stuff
so I think the 13 o'clock in minutes
format wasn't really I mean because it
didn't have us talking it just had music
voiceover and like cool graphics and
stuff but so people couldn't put it on
in the background and just like
listening to us I'm pretty sure the name
of the third channel that will open up
will have our normal 13 o'clock podcast
show which is what you're watching now
we're gonna have our movie reviews yes
and I'm pretty sure this third one's
gonna be called time machine 13 like I
haven't made any of the videos yet but
we have not yet oh she wants to be on
the show right but just like on the
audio because she always she's tested me
but yeah so that's definitely something
that's kind of coming in the future time
machine 13 yeah I think we said
something about it on I think there's a
last episode or the one before that my
general my general idea I'm just gonna
run this by you now good what the time
machine 13 is gonna be about cool stuff
that no longer exists but you remember
that's what we're gonna talk about at
least we were at least we were better
all the people like us remember right
and I'm gonna be able to tie this into a
bunch of other things and Jenny's gonna
have hers and and I'm gonna have mine in
other words so the videos gonna be my
idea so I'm gonna be her ideas and we're
to talk about stuff that's gone yeah we
have a big list of stuff that we
remember from our childhood yes because
those things are going away I can
predict what's gonna go away in the
future because everything's
interconnected he's not so we're talking
like Nostradamus it's gonna be a time
machine because this is a long-standing
joke between Eminem yeah Nostradamus
toaster Tom Schiff that's another
t-shirt I should make I never thought
about that although you it is true I do
dick things that come true even a weird
[ __ ] I've just had an idea that certain
things would happen and they did happen
some stuff that I never could have
predicted although I kind of feel like
there's confirmation bias well just well
just like in every other Nostradamus
thing it's like you only remember stuff
that actually happened you don't
remember something I never would have
imagined the impact that the internet
had would have I don't think anyone I
don't think I never really would have
imagined that 2018 looks like this now
we talked about this a little bit on one
of our what was it I think it was
running man we talked a little bit about
about this on the running man show about
how nobody ever gets the future right I
think they always they always take it
too far in one direction and not far
enough in the other direction right like
they don't take it far enough in the
pragmatic direction but then they're
like look everyone's gonna be wearing
jumpsuits with these big triangular
shoulder pads that [ __ ] like that you
know what I mean it's like they always
kind of go the wrong way with it or they
extrapolate from the wrong things yeah
it is always happen but yeah we kind of
talked about a little bit on them right
man yeah but so you won't do the
shoutouts yeah let's do the shoutouts
and then we'll do the news like I said
the news is also kind of depressing but
you know that's just a shake this is not
gonna be a depressing show don't worry
folks I make this [ __ ] funny I'm just
we'll see we'll see how it goes yeah
okay so first thing I want to shout out
if you haven't seen our latest movie
review it was David Cronenberg's
first feature film shivers also known as
they came from within or aracite murders
or orgy of the blood parasites yeah
which I actually kind of wish he'd
called it he didn't but yeah so that was
our last movie review so go check that
out also check out our Zazzle sword
zazzle.com slash searching the clock and
we've got a whole bunch of t-shirts and
a tote bag and also I need to make an
Oscar Thomas t-shirt that just reminds
me soon find me to write that down and
also if you know sir Thomas Mann who saw
tomorrow yeah nostra Thomas predicts
he's like Chris well I'm gonna do I'm
gonna do like an Edward one mother
please okay do what you want thank you
notes to Thomas is better though
well I know it's no one's making a value
judgment about that also if you'd like
to financially support the show go to
our patreon page at patreon.com slash 13
o'clock or go to our blog which is 13
o'clock Doug calm and there's a link in
the sidebar to a page right now
just like our buddy Richard did sent us
a PayPal donation thank you very much
yeah awesome help us reach 1,000 dollars
a month and we'll release the new
channel on yeah because we are
definitely talking about this working on
it I've actually started working on the
first video yeah decided we were gonna
have them hostage and we're gonna get it
back cameras better microphones are
gonna have better lighting we're gonna
do green screen so it's gonna be a
better show and the next month or so
yeah even though this is a very nice
background I should say this is a
painting yeah a little bit of glare on
that that's all right well it's yeah
that's our that's our outside that's the
portrait we're not tropical lounge this
is just wait for alligators to walk by
yeah oh and oh thank you that was a very
good segue into our news stories this
first news story well let's call it a
news story and for those of you
listening to the audience I am making
ironic what a rabbit ears as Eddie
Izzard says so this news story was sent
to me by a listener and it is your cuz
remember like the last like last week's
story when I said oh this is the most
Florida story imaginable though you know
the guy that just committed to his that
made it look like a murder Bible tying
the gun of the balloon or whatever this
is actually the most Florida story ever
so apparently this story made the rounds
of this guy named Shaun kilims I want to
say and he was arrested in Florida for
allegedly tranquilizing and raping
alligators no [ __ ] no well yeah I'm
getting to that now the best thing about
this is the mug shot so the link that
the girl sent me this mug shot is
everything it is the best mug shot ever
taken
if this guy looks like he's all pop-eyed
he looks like a cartoon are you showing
in the mug shot [ __ ] like that yes I'm
that's the best part of this story now
evidently so according to the story this
guy Shawn was arrested getting busy with
the alligators after he had roofied them
I'm not buying it and well okay well I'm
getting there okay
and you know he was arrested by police
they had to tase him because he wasn't
listening to them and stuff and then
they determined he was on crystal meth
and all this other kind of stuff well
you know as luck would have it the
venerable Snopes looked into this story
is like this story yeah did not happen
it is actually it was actually first
published by a satire site kind of like
the onion but it was a different one
then I had a feeling that was yeah I
didn't think that was possible right
thank you although it should be noted
that the wonderful wonderful mug shot is
a real actual mug shot okay but the guy
in the mug is not an alligator rapist
and he is not from Florida he's actually
from Ohio and all he was arrested for it
was yeah oh hi Ohio man Ohio was the
Florida of the North yeah so he was
actually arrested and for just growing
pot in his house which whatever who
cares so but the guy but the the mug
shot is great but you know the poor guy
got splashed all over the Internet as an
alligator rapist when really he was just
growing some weed in his house that's
all he did even though he has the
craziest mugshot ever seen now the
weirdest thing about this story though
is that when I googled it in order to
get some photos for the video I found
that there had been another story going
around back in 2016 it was all over
Facebook your grandma probably emailed
it to you and everything like that
because she doesn't know when things are
real or not and it was the same kind of
thing that a zoo keeper in Naples which
are presuming is Naples Florida not
Naples Italy because I don't think they
have alligators in Italy at least not in
the wild
so apparently a zookeeper had been in
the process of raping a juvenile
alligator when a big one snuck up on him
and ate him no but that did not happen
either I'm sorry to disappoint you
however the news story that made the
rounds about the guy that flung the
alligator into the Wendy's drive-through
window is true like no one's like
Hawking a [ __ ] 28 but crazy out into
the wind 'yes but you know but that did
happen in florida somebody did actually
throw an alligator into the wedding
which you know probably you work in fast
food that's probably the like the last
thing you ever think would ever happen
or one of the last things he ever think
would ever ever happen now this other
story is this sadly really did happen
now this was also sent to me by a
listener and I was thinking about doing
a whole episode on it but I'm like no
because I'll just cry during the whole
thing this is about the croydon cat
killer oh that guy yeah
now well it might not be a guy it might
it be more it might be more than one guy
right or a girl but I doubt it it's
probably a dude I have to say not to be
sexist or anything but yeah so the
croydon cat killer also known as the UK
cat killer or the m25 calculator because
that's where a lot of the victims they
play it along the m25 is thought to have
killed dismembered mutilated about 500
cats in the UK usually kills them
evidently he's been luring them by using
like raw chicken and then he either I
don't know how he kills them like they
think that some of them died from blunt
trauma as though they'd been thrown
against a wall and then he takes off
their heads and their tails and takes
them order system I guess where is this
again in England but it started in
Croydon but there have been some as
northa as far north as Manchester so
they don't know if it's one guy or with
do you remember witnessed a bunch of
copycat killers it started in 2014 and
it's still kind of ongoing every now and
then now there's still like
little bit of debate there have been
like a kid yeah there have been like a
really lot of them and some people are
saying oh well it's probably not even a
person it's just like a fox but what a
fox really routinely take the head and
the tail of the cat and leave the rest
of it there well if it's eaten it may be
but still I mean that's like yeah and
it's just like so there's reports like
all around London and stuff stray cats
people's cats that you know they could
be a couple of boys doing it I kind of
it better be and yes if you kids are out
there and you're watching this show
right now you listen to me right kick
your [ __ ] ass if you are anyone like
you yeah never laid a finger on my baby
cookie or my Beijing I will reach my
hands into your anal cavity and I will
turn you inside out like a cheap handbag
okay that is like you know what I mean
it's like yeah we talked about like a
lot of murderers of people on this show
and that sucks too you also suck but
really killing little kitties you're
going little puppies it's like killing
children yeah I just don't it's the
worst Americans don't stand for that
[ __ ] no well British people don't eat
yes yeah and in in places in the United
States especially in the south
you kill a man's dog he's gonna kill you
most likely you know we got guns over
here rightfully so you kill somebody's
dog that's equivalent of killing
somebody's child you're a dead man and
like I said I am not averse to that I
mean seriously if you know it's one
thing if you heat it with your car and
it's an accident okay that's
like--that's yeah that's different I'm
talk about going out of your way to do
something bad to somebody's pet that's
like doing something bad just somebody's
child
that's like doing something they're a
kid because we we have two cats you
won't be found you won't be found right
if they find you you'll be off in a
ditch I want you in a stew and eat you
I'm sick no I'm totally serious about
that no I'm going to taste good too lean
that's all right okay it's the principle
all right I don't care about the taste
and I mask anything it tastes like pork
it'd be nice like pork soup yeah we can
make a licked I'll be good but yeah so
that's that's the thing it's like if
this is a person or people doing that's
like what one what the [ __ ] is your
problem
you it's like this is like serial killer
[ __ ] and if they don't catch this
[ __ ] or [ __ ] now this
is gonna escalate into killing people
because this is how serial killers gets
yeah they kill little defenseless
animals and you know what I mean I swear
to god this this story just like I was
reading the Wikipedia page because
someone said oh you should do the court
and cat killer and I'm like oh that
doesn't sound like something I want to
read about but I went to the Wikipedia
page you know I was just like oh oh oh
it's just like so bummed out because I
love my kitties and it's like I mean we
have two cats and like I said if anybody
did anything to any of my cat so you
would just you would wish you were dead
yeah I've seen some videos coming out of
Europe but certain things that happen to
people's dog that doesn't happen where
I'm from him from Mississippi you attack
somebody's pet dog they will set you on
fire I'm not and then literally they
will kill you
and like I said I wouldn't I was
honestly Mississippi purifies things by
fire yeah that's right yeah no I'm just
saying like when when I lived in Daytona
many years ago and I used to work on the
night shift at a newspaper
remember those for all you kids it was
it was made of huge things like the
internet but it was so funny I was in
the store I was it I was in wait at a
winn-dixie as we had dad down south and
there was an old guy holding up the line
he must've been about 80 and he held up
the line for a good 15 minutes cuz he
tried to buy a newspaper the people that
were running the register didn't even
know how to pay them they're just like
what is this and then I saw what a
newspaper looked like today it was just
pitiful pitiful it had maybe 30 pages
well yeah how did you newspapers used to
look well I I remember I go that's a
newspaper I works for one for many years
they put a flyer yeah and really even
years and years ago they started losing
yeah the page count went down like by
half that was like years ago what do you
buy on that [ __ ] for but that was that
was a universe he knew that's what he
was came from imagine to him it was like
the apocalypse what happened to my
newspaper now we're gonna look at it all
day I can't
ridiculous no okay I'm gonna hold you to
that
yeah so so anyway before I was rudely
interrupted I was driving home from my
job one night and I was driving back to
my house and I saw a kitty in the road
and someone had tied a plastic bag over
its head yeah with a wire and I don't
like stop and I'd like pulled the yeah
you tow like I couldn't get that was
years years ago like I had a coat I
couldn't get it off again she kept like
climbs can we try to choose a hole in it
so she could breathe it least Sonny was
trying to suffocate and I was just like
aah and like and I've heard about people
that like they had cats and then oh the
cats had kittens and we couldn't get rid
of them so they put all the kittens in a
bag and then like threw in a river it's
like [ __ ] hell man right
you could kittens I mean cats are pretty
self you know they can live in the wild
it's like it would be better just like
leave them in the woods they'd probably
be all right yeah [ __ ] man I mean like
our our little cookies like she got
found in someone's backyard like a dog
was attacking her and she gotta drop the
whole drought on things now I've never
even I never thought that was humane at
all I mean of course not no I mean how
could you if you have if you if you have
an unwanted a litter of kittens I mean
you know I've heard of people shooting
them you know but that's instant you
know least instant how could you they're
so cute some people bet it was back in
the day that was a long time ago they're
alive it was a long time ago you know
before they had animal control you know
nose out of that country 70s and then in
the 70s they used to be a constant just
too many good your cat gave birth to too
many cats you know that kind of deal I
would just keep cat ladies you got
hundreds of them you know that's all
right I would rather do that then like
how can you like shoot a kitty you can't
do it so anyway yeah so sorry that that
was a story was so depressing seriously
if anybody knows anything about this cat
killer turn this sucker individual turn
them in yeah because they are gonna be
as and it's bad enough that they're
killing sweet little kitty cats because
they're doing it too like bunnies and
[ __ ] too it's not just cats it's mostly
cats sounds like a couple little kids a
couple badass
teenagers wellyes need you a swift well
yeah more than that they need somebody
needs to turn that [ __ ] in their parents
is just somebody so somebody do
something about that [ __ ] so they can
help you stars I'm not down there
we might come over there just [ __ ] your
mama
the reason you're wrong I like it I like
it if I could kick your grandparents and
your great-grandparents s how we have
that [ __ ] that's how we handle it over
here right that's exactly right
so yeah generational generation might
hit you so hard your grandparents that's
right jung-hoon knows all about it
all right so yes sorry sorry about the
depressing depressing news stories but
if that wasn't depressing enough now
we're gonna talk about the snow town
murders of Australia news is done
already yes damn what what I mean
already we went on that seems like that
happen fast all right okay all right
we'll get to it so here's the snow town
murders enjoy all right so let's get
into our main topic which has been
requested several times I think at least
two or three times this is the snow town
murders of Australia probably other than
the backpacker killer whose name is
Yvonne mullet I think this guy or guys
is actually Australia's most prolific
serial killer there's actually two of
them sort of it doesn't ring a bell to
me I don't think I know this they
actually made a movie about it in 2011
that was just called snow town that was
based on it and it was actually on
Netflix for a while and I kept meaning
to watch it and then I never got around
to watching it and then when I looked
for it the other day it wasn't there
anymore so if I've heard it's a very
unpleasant movie to watch and I can
imagine that it probably is because he's
a very unpleasant kind of case yeah
the thing about this case that's so
weird I mean other than just the
horrific nature of you know these people
were tortured and murdered and things
like that this is also called the bodies
and the barrels murders but it's the
fact that it was really
a group of four but there was even an
extended there was like extended people
that kind of helped out on various
things and these people generally did
not target random people these people
targeted their friends their neighbors
their relatives oh I think I know this
[ __ ] like that
guy no this one man you know what I mean
and then like some of the people that
people knew about it yeah like some of
the people that were involved in the
earlier murders like later got murdered
themselves like by this guy didn't this
guy have some property and he had like a
big shed with a bunch of mechanic stuff
and he was in cars and things like that
out or is that was that an American case
yeah I think that's something that might
be some all right so uh but I kind of
know the situations every now and then
these kind of situations pop up where
it's a guy who owns property and he has
a lot of friends who know him and they
manipulates them all and to bring him
kind of like victims and they knock
people yeah that's kind of like this I
mean even though ultimately four people
were convicted of various crimes around
this crime spree yeah but this guy they
pretty much think he was the ringleader
like you know I don't know if any of the
other people would have necessarily gone
down this particular route and it's kind
of sad because it was really kind of
this group of sort of vulnerable people
kind of degenerate yeah they kind of
lived in this role like working-class
yeah area like north of Adelaide the
other Clintons the other case I'm
thinking about is the exact same profile
they're in an area that's like
economically imputing yeah and it's
everything's going away because the you
know whatever kept that town or city and
business is gone like say it might be a
steel mill or something like that and
the town kinda goes post-apocalyptic
yeah all the good people leave and
leaves behind all these other kind of
like scavengers yeah who are picking
apart the corpse of a dying City and you
know and they all get real poor and they
fall into drugs and then they start
falling into like murder it's like a
murder cult that's usually how it
happens this seems like that was kind of
like what was going on like that in this
situation sort of all right now the
interesting thing about this was that
really nobody knew that all of this
stuff was going on for many years
until a sort of routine examination of
some cold-case missing-persons kind of
stuff and then they started making all
the connections so I kind of want to
start there because I thought that was
kind of interesting how they found out
about this all right now what they were
doing those two different documentaries
on YouTube about this and both of them
are pretty good but they differ a little
bit in the details but it's not really
that big of a deal
pretty much what happened was you know
one of the guys in the interview said
well every now and then when we have
some downtime in the police department
you know we go back over cold cases like
missing-persons cases and whatever and
they're like and so we were just doing
that as a routine we were going back
through we picked ten cases that seemed
like they might be homicides or they
seemed suspicious and we started going
back through them now one of the cases
that they were examining was the case of
a young guy named Clinton true size and
he had actually disappeared he had been
gone since 1992 although he actually
wasn't reported missing until 1995 now
what they thought was kind of weird was
that the more they looked into his case
he had been associated with this other
guy named Barry Lane who was an older
guy in his 40s Barry Lane was a
crossdresser
he was thought to be a pedophile now
Clinton sure size had actually lived
with Barry Lane in the 90s and they
allegedly were in a sexual relationship
they probably were but the weird thing
about it was that in 1997 Barry Lane had
gone missing too he had been reported
missing by his family so the police
thought that's kind of odd that these
two missing people were associated with
each other and had lived together at
some point
so they start kind of looking into it
and the interesting thing too about when
they started looking into the Barry lane
case they said even though he was
reported missing in 1997 someone was
still routinely taking money out of his
bank account you know they're like huh
well that could mean that he's still
alive or that somebody killed him and
has got
ATM card so they kind of wanted to start
looking into that so they were looking
into that for a few months and then
comes November of 1998 and then this
woman is reported missing her name is
Elizabeth Hayden
she was actually reported missing by her
brother now the more they look into her
disappearance they brought in her
husband Mark Hayden and they thought it
was kind of strange that he had not
reported her missing and also that he
didn't really seem all that concerned
about where she had gone she's like oh
you know she just left me and I don't
know where she is now all right right
and they said they thought that was a
little weird so these three crimes while
they were investigating these three
missing-persons cases they noticed that
the same two names kept coming up as
like being associated with all these
people and these two names were John
bunting and Robert Wagner Robert Wagner
had also been a boyfriend of berry Lane
and they had lived together for a very
long time like nine ten years something
like that
John bunting had actually befriended he
had moved to this particular
neighborhood in 1991 north of Adelaide
this is in South Australia in case I
didn't mention it and he so they had
been friends with them for a long time
now police began to suspect because
these two guys kept coming up and it's
like you know all these people that were
missing we're like kind of related or
friends or neighbors or knew one another
in some capacity so they were able to
know like well here's what we're gonna
do we're gonna set up some surveillance
to see who is taking the money out of
Barry lanes account yeah so they set up
the thing with the ATM or they you know
pull the records the camera records of
the ATM and they discovered that Barry
lanes money has been being taken out of
his account by Robert Wagner so now we
have three missing people yeah and these
two guys seem to be coming up in all
three of these missing persons
investigations yeah you know so now you
have Elizabeth Hayden and then they
found out that her husband Mark Hayden
was also friends with these two idiots
yeah well that's not supposed to happen
that's that's not statistically not
possible that means that these people
are the linchpins to all these other
missing persons cases you know they're
in common with
he's missing-persons cases that's not
good well yeah that's what I mean so
that's why police were just kind of like
okay well there's obviously something
going on here now they're like what we
need to do they at this point they they
went to a judge and they said can we tap
their phones can we do these other
things they were also trying to find
Elizabeth Hayden had like a van they
call it a Land Cruiser it was like a big
like white and brown like kind of a
grungy looking van and they didn't know
where it was they said well maybe if we
find that you know we'll find out where
some of these people are gone it's have
gone and stuff so eventually they put
these guys under surveillance
particularly bunting and Wagner and so
one day they have a bunch of cops follow
them you know just on the down-low yeah
these two guys drive up to this little
bitty town about 90 miles north of
Adelaide called snow town this is a
little tiny like farming community maybe
a couple hundred people so like mom I
wonder why they're going up there
apparently they had a friend up there
that they were going to visit so they
followed them up to this little town
called snow town now while they're up
there they see the two guys and they
pull into this the driveway of this
house and they see Elizabeth Hayden's
van yeah and they're like huh that's
interesting we've been looking for that
van all over the place right it belongs
to a missing woman so then they go and
ask this neighbor this friend of theirs
that they've been visiting like after
they leave they're like oh yeah you know
they brought this van here the other day
they were unloading a bunch of big black
barrels and they're like oh and they
rented this disused bank building across
the street and they put all that stuff
in there there was this old it was like
this old bank building it hadn't really
been used for anything it was kind of
empty they were using it just for like
old computer parts storage and stuff
like that so they said yeah these guys
rented this building and I saw them like
unloading the barrels in there right so
the cops are like okay so and there's
actually video of them first entering
this vault yeah so they go into the bank
where the vault is it's like there's a
little door and then there's like all of
this black plastic and it's like taped
all the way around the door yeah and
they're like oh boy so they cut it a so
show them slowly cutting it open and
they look and then they just the smell
was just indescribable really yeah so
they said inside this disused
bankfull they find six very very large
black barrels yeah
and a whole bunch of disturbing looking
tools pliers saws right a thing to
electrocute people with oh and rope yeah
[ __ ] like that right obviously they're
kind of just like I hate my [ __ ] job
today they open up one and I love they
they interviewed one of the
investigators that was there when they
you know when they first went into the
vault and he is so I guess you get this
way after a while up to him he's just so
matter-of-fact yeah he's like you know I
had called up the coroner I said yeah we
got these big barrels here and the
coroner's like well what do you think it
is he's like well judging by the smell
I'm bar you can probably assume so he's
like so the first barrel he's like I
opened it up and he's like and
immediately I see a mummified foot yeah
right yeah he's like so basically the
gist of it is there are six barrels with
a whole [ __ ] ton of cut-up body parts in
them okay
now in the vault they also found like a
whole bunch of bottles of hydrochloric
acid now evidently these killers had
thought that if they had poured the
hydrochloric acid into the barrels yeah
with these body parts that it would
dissolve them yeah unfortunately the
hydrochloric acid was neutralized by all
the water in the bodies yeah so it
basically just mummified yeah the body
okay so I mean the coroner was on the
coroner like was interviewed and he's
like man we still saw tattoos we still
got fingerprints we could still tell how
most of them died or the body it didn't
destroy the body at all there like in
fact three of the victims still had rope
around their necks um you know some of
them had burn marks and things like that
so at this stage they're like okay they
didn't know how many bodies it was
because you know it was it was all they
were all cut up and they were all in
different pieces so basically they had
to pour all the acid out of the barrels
and take all the body part he's like we
just picked up all the body parts and
put them out on the tables and tried to
like match them all up like some
grotesque jigsaw puzzle to figure out
how many bodies this was you know what's
weird is that these guys have no problem
you know like killing people on tour
Turnham stuff like that but then they
have a problem disposing of the bodies
yeah baby deer hunter knows how to
dispose of a large body it's not
difficult it's not even gross well it's
like why the hell would you just keep
him but because yeah it should be noted
that where the bodies turned up in the
bank vault that wasn't where they had
started out I mean he been keeping them
at various pleas they were just moving
him around because they thought that the
cops were on to them yeah so they
decided well we're gonna move them up to
this remote location and they'll never
find it's just funny how you know they
put all this effort into killing people
and torturing them but not in into
efficient body processing yeah that's
way you want to put it I mean butchers
do it all day you know I mean it's just
a different species of animal and
instead they just you know keep rotting
body parts around inside of barrels and
you know it's just dumb well done yeah I
I have to say that really none of these
killers were the sharpest knives and
yeah ridiculous so you know what I mean
so it's it's kind of a question of yeah
and like I said you know where the
bodies ended up that wasn't where I mean
they only kept they only took them there
right you know later on and like after
they thought oh well we can't keep him
in my shed or wherever the [ __ ] that
we're keeping anymore now after these
two guys were arrested like a few days
after they were arrested there was an
anonymous tip someone called it an
anonymous tip and said hey might want to
also check out buntings former house
because he had moved since then he's
like cuz I think there's a couple bodies
buried there too right so they went to
that house and they dug up the backyard
and they found two more bodies there so
what we're looking at basically in the
barrels that was eight bodies yeah
they also found two in this douches
former backyard and they found one that
had been buried somewhere else so you're
looking at ultimately the two guys were
convicted of 11 murders possibly a 12th
but they didn't have enough to prove
that one even though they found her body
cut up in the backyard too they said oh
she just died of natural causes and we
just cut her I'm like yeah okay but you
know they didn't have enough evidence
but then still you know they still got
11 people so I'm gonna stop her and take
a break right here and then we come
I'm gonna talk a little bit about the
killers and I'm gonna talk about the
victims and how this [ __ ] all the motors
and all that yeah and all that kind of
stuff so we're gonna take a break we
will be back in just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
and I think that's why it's so
significant because we are willing to
put pen to paper and conclude at the end
of the day at this house and we'll
continue to be on the Buddy Ginny's got
some new shirt designs up four of them
really good ones to Atlanta Ripper who
put Bella in the which out the HH Holmes
murder castle and of course demon child
cuz man said he could these are updated
designs I think they look really cool
Jenny did a great job
bottom where they found making Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out right yeah it
really good they're very high quality
shirts Jenny and I we're sure our own
shirts at certain times when we're
trying to put spotlight on ourselves and
you can put a spotlight on yourselves if
you go ahead and pick up on these shirts
today you guys are gonna love them makes
in the description WWL comm at 13
o'clock yes ago check out our store at
WWE as well comm / 13 o'clock we got
these four cool new t-shirt designs plus
all our old ones if you'd rather get one
at all ones but these ones are awesome
and you should check them out they're
also available in women's cut they look
really cute JT's got some so thank you
go check them out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay now the ringleader of this group of
scumbags yeah john justin bunting now
evidently he came from a pretty normal
middle-class were working-class family
but when he was young
according to psychologists and you know
various investigators that have looked
into his background he started to
exhibit your classic kind of serial
killer behavior he seemed to enjoy
killing and torturing animals when he
was a teenager he became a neo-nazi you
know things of that nature he seemed
very intelligent but he seemed to have
no empathy now he claims that when he
was a teenager a friend of his brother
sexually assaulted him I'm not sure if
that's true it could very well be but
evidently this incident you know
although he was kind of screwed up
before that happened but this incident
seemed to solidify his hatred of gay
people his hatred of pedophiles yeah his
hatred of anyone that was weak or
feminine right he was one of those very
kind of hardcore you know he was raised
very conservatively so he was one of
those and he fancied himself something
of a vigilante that it was his job to
rid the world of degenerates of gay
people of drug addicts of people who
were worthless or useless yes so that
was kind of his motivating factor and I
think that he held that belief that he
was doing something not good necessarily
but he was doing a righteous thing yeah
even when he went to trial and even
though even though as the murders
progressed they became more and more
horrific more involving more more
torture hey listen yeah it was just
pretty much it's his excuse all right a
reason cuz he seemed to really enjoy
it's like those guys that kill all those
processes well I gotta stop all these
[ __ ] yeah it was frame spreading these
diseases to these men yeah
self-justification it's like
you just enjoy killing people and
torturing people and inflicting pain and
you don't really want to admit that to
yourself I suppose so you try to couch
it in this time on a righteous crusade
Kyoto that is yeah that is evidently
where this dude was coming from now he
even had something he called it the rock
spider wall he had it in this house and
it was basically pictures and articles
and stuff like that about people that he
knew or people in the neighborhood that
he's suspected of being gay or he's
suspected of being pedophiles and he's
like so he had them like all over the
wall with like little pieces of yarn
yeah who's this guy's related to this
guy and this guy is guy and all this
other kind of [ __ ] right yeah and so he
would have all his buddies and his
neighbors and stuff like that that would
come over and he would like rant at them
these [ __ ] [ __ ] and pedophiles oh
we need to get rid of him and we knew
this and that but the ironic thing was
that his partner in crime Robert Wagner
yeah was also a gay man or at least
bisexual right yeah and had been in a
homosexual relationship for a very long
time very lame now the interesting thing
was that berry Lane yeah I was laughs
I'm sorry I know you know you know house
I can imagine so
berry Lane like I said everything I've
said said yeah yeah he was probably a
pedophile because he had been in a
relationship with Robert Wagner yeah
since Robert Wagner was 13 years old so
berry Lane was friends with these two
people yeah with the two main killers
but really it seems like John bunting
only kept berry Lane around because he
wanted the skinny on other pedophiles
and other gay people in the neighborhood
like he wanted this guy to like give him
info yeah this guy's a dirtbag that
guy's a pedophile and stuff so he could
like you know have victims for later
yeah now berry Lane apparently did help
in some of the early murders yeah
now the first victim and they didn't
find out about this until much later
like I said this guy wasn't he went
missing in 1992 but wasn't reported
missing until 1995 and then they didn't
find him until much later
this kid was named Clinton Troost
as I said he was 22 years old and he was
suspected of being a pedophile I don't
think he really was
for whatever reason John bunting just
didn't like I more thought he wanted to
you know so he invites this kid over and
to his house like to hang out and then
he beats him to death with a shovel and
then you know buries him in a shallow
grave in lower light South Australia so
you know that was that was unsolved for
a long time now the next person they
killed was named Ray Davies and he was
actually kind of mentally challenged
yeah he actually lived behind he lived
like in a trailer behind the house of
this of this woman named Suzanne Allen
who was another one of the victims and
like I said all these people knew each
other I think only one of the people
they killed was a total and complete
stranger yeah you know what I mean so
this is like this whole network of
people that all know each other their
friends their relatives and there's like
oh well I'll help you with this murder
and then later on they get killed - this
guy's a real genius yeah so Ray Davies
as far as I know did not was not
involved with any murders or anything
like that but they just killed him
because Suzanne Allen who would also be
killed by these by this gang of idiots
later she said Oh Ray Davies made sexual
advances toward my grandsons therefore
he's a pedophile therefore he deserves
to get killed like I said I don't know
if that was true or not that's just made
it may be she made it up maybe he made
it up because Suzanne Allen's dead so
right you know he's my maid so he just
probably made that up like I got the
feeling this just looking for justice I
got the feeling that this guy just likes
to torture and kill people and he's just
that's what he's gonna make up some kind
of a reason for you to go ahead and do
that's exactly what he seems like he can
feel good about himself saying I'm you
know society would approve of what I'm
doing yeah well I mean basically when he
went on trial they're they're like
here's the thing of this documentary
that I saw about it they're like okay
well the prosecution's case took like a
hundred and fifty days or something like
that because they had so much evidence
so many witnesses they're like the
defense 18 minutes yeah they're like
neither guy even said anything about it
there's basically
bunting just stood up there and was like
kind of like well I was ridding the
world of pedophiles you're welcome
yeah that was like about it yeah and I
was like okay yeah I know I'm naughty
but so yeah so Ray Davies was also
killed now he was one of the ones that
was found in the backyard of buntings
former home so he wasn't one of the ones
that was in neither of these have were
in the barrels the next one they killed
was Michael gardener now he was actually
killed in August of 1997 he just lived
nearby the reason that bunting wanted
him dead was because he was gay that's
it and really he equated gay with
pedophiles who didn't care you know he
thought that was the same thing so so
yeah that was why he was killed
I should also note that where possible
they would torture these people
beforehand to get their pin numbers to
get their cards and stuff like that so
they could continue to collect their
welfare or their unemployment payments
after they were dead yeah like that
won't get you caught yes yeah another
thing that they would do and they also
did this in in the case of their victim
Michael gardener was that they would
have one of their other friends
impersonate him like over the phone like
they would call their relatives and go
oh I'm going overseas or I'm going
somewhere else you know I don't want to
talk to you anymore and [ __ ] like that
or impersonate them like to collect
their welfare payments and stuff like
that so that actually happened in
Michael Gardens changed this plan is
planter like I said not the brightest
bulbs so that happened in the case of
Michael gardener one of the later
victims whose name was Fred Brooks was a
friend of gardeners and they actually
made Fred Brooks impersonate Michael
gardener later but Fred Brooks would get
killed later on yeah now berry Lane was
the next one to get killed now he had
actually helped in a couple of the
earlier murders and like I said he had
been in a longtime relationship with
Robert Wagner one of the two main to
main killers because he thought he was
immune but his number came up that's
what I mean well eventually like I said
most of the people associated with these
yeah creeps ended up dead at some point
Yeah right all their friends relatives
everything that's weird
yes weird that they that he was all is
that he helped in some of the murders
and he thought that you know he's gonna
get away scot-free I guess so so yeah
berry Lane obviously was openly gay he
was
an alleged pedophile he was last seen
alive in October of 1997 and like I said
one of his missing persons his family
actually reported him missing and it was
Robert Wagner picking up his you know
taking money out of his account that
kind of made them super suspicious about
these I'm not I don't feel too bad about
that one though yeah well he was another
one he was helped he kind of seemed like
a scumbag I mean you know it's it's not
cool what it's like murder but he was
helping he wasn't like an innocent
bystander I don't know if he held it if
he actually killed anybody but he did
for sure like knew about it and he
helped them like conceal the bodies and
stuff of course so yeah he was one of
the ones that was found in the barrels
their next victim was named Thomas
travillian and he kind of he had
paranoid schizophrenia he was one of
those guys that would like you know run
out with a knife like every time I heard
a noise and he was like kind of crazy
and stuff so he had actually been in a
relationship with berry lane too at some
point in 1997 now the reason that they
know all of this stuff about all the
relationships and stuff because one of
the kid I guess he was like 19 or 20 and
his name is James Vlahakis
and he was actually the son of John
buntings girlfriend or wife at the time
and he actually ended up helping out but
later on he felt so horrible that he had
got sucked into all this stuff that he
actually turned state's evidence and
told everything right so everything that
now he he agreed to plead guilty to four
counts of murder okay because he wasn't
involved from the very beginning but he
knew about it later on and you know he
said I was scared of John but I was
scared they would kill me he's like I
saw them killed my friends my relatives
you know I saw it so I didn't want to
you know make him mad obviously what'd
he get 26 years he got 26 counts that's
pretty light well they gave him a
lighter sentence because he turned he
ratted all the other ball congruent so
he ran him all along yeah yeah so Thomas
rebellion like I said now he was
involved in the murder of Barry Lane who
had also he had also been in a
relationship with now what they did they
actually didn't investigate his death
they actually found him dead in November
of 1997 but they thought it was a
suicide
cuz bunting and Wagner had just made him
stand on a box and then they
and so it would look like a suicide but
he was actually murdered
now the next one was a guy named Gavin
Porter he was 31 now he was a friend of
James Vlahakis like I said he was kind
of like the stepson I guess of John
bunting and he actually moved into the
house with John bunting and James Lusaka
sand elizabeth Haley Harley I want to
say is the is the mom's name so they all
moved in together now I think it was
just because he was a drug addict like
he was a heroin he was in gay he was in
pedophile I don't think I think the only
reason that John Bundy killed him was
like oh I think heroin users are a waste
of skin and you know so I'm just gonna
kill that guy too
he was basically he'd been working on
his car and he fell asleep out in this
car they just dragged him out of car and
[ __ ] killed him and then cut him up
and put him in a barrel next one was
Troy you'd who was actually James Lusa
kisses half-brother yeah James Lucas
told John bunting that Troy you'd had
molested him when he was a kid
so of course bunting took that as his
cue and is like okay well I'm gonna kill
that one twos they dragged him out of
his bed and murdered him wonderfully
this is true or they just that's what I
mean many people allegedly because like
I said a lot of this is coming from
bunting or coming from James Lusaka so
you know as something that John bunting
said too many pedophiles in one spot
that's what I mean and it's it's crazy
because like some of the like I said
there's two documentaries about it one
of the documentaries has like
reenactments yeah and you can imagine
that the real John bunting probably did
sound a lot like this is you like
everywhere like spit files they're on
every corner dirty it's blood I'm like
yeah that's probably exactly what he did
like it's like you know anything I I
haven't it I have an idea that he's that
kind of dude I do driven yeah and like I
said he seemed very and even when he
went him and Robert Wagner were standing
trial they were just very defiant they
kept like flicking off the cameras like
you know you're welcome they were like
that it's like and then you know if you
kind of fell in with him you knew that
up all you had to do to get somebody
killed was to call somebody else will
terrify you could trigger him easily
yeah hey Matt dude over there yeah
that's exactly what of you know yeah
he's got those he's got those eyes yeah
well and honestly one of the
psychologists that they interviewed on
the thing was like John bunting really
did believe that he could tell you were
a child molester just by looking at you
yeah
right yeah so but like I said you didn't
know is just like that guy that would
stab random women he says I could just
see the devil in them some of them I
could just see it you can see the devil
I know and like I said you didn't have
to be a child molester you could just be
gay you could just be a drug addict she
could just be saw you and I saw that you
were the devil and I just killed you
yeah pretty much yeah
yeah so the next one that got killed was
Frederick Brooks and he was actually the
the nephew of Elizabeth Hayden who was
one of the ones that was murdered later
he was actually murdered in September of
1998 by John bunting
Wagner and James Lucas and he was also
kind of mentally challenged yeah he I
don't think he helped out in any of the
murders I think they made him
impersonate one of their other victims
yeah I don't know why they killed him
other than they just thought he knew too
much they killed him he was like I said
he was kind of mentally challenged he
had was on welfare or on disability and
they continued to collect that after
they killed him the next guy was Gary
O'Dwyer damn is this a lot of people
what are we at now uh and well like I
said overall they were convicted of 11
okay and there was another one - yeah
that was probably but they just didn't
have enough evidence Gary O'Dwyer was
another mentally challenged man he
actually was on disability because he'd
had a car accident early in his life and
had a sustained brain damage this was
the only guy that was pretty much a
stranger to them the only reason that he
was targeted was because they thought oh
well he's [ __ ] and he's on
disability and he's weak and weak and
he's just a weed is taking the people's
money yes so he had a lot of really bad
torture a lot of them did what they
would do generally they would crush
people's toes with pliers they would
burn their testicles and chests with
like a electrical what you call it I
don't remember what the name of it is
but it's some kind of electrical
something that you can electrocute
people with okay now it was like I don't
I didn't recognize like what the name of
it was maybe it's different in every
sure
that's the thing that can burn you an
electrical thing that burns you yeah
okay and also one of the victims and
he's gonna squirm when I say this one of
the victims they lit a sparkler and put
it into his pee hole Dan yeah yeah see
he just quenched this like well I'd well
too bad I just told you yeah
that was one of the victims had that
done to them as well so like I said this
is clearly people that are getting off
on this yeah so the next victim was
Elizabeth Hayden this was the wife of
Mark Hayden who actually knew about all
the murders and helped them to get rid
of some of the bodies they speculate
that Elizabeth Hayden might have known
about them too which might have been why
she got killed it was actually her being
missing that sort of triggered off the
whole investigation that led to all of
them finding all these bodies
apparently I think that bunting just
killed her because she was fat he didn't
like fat people yeah yeah yeah yeah he
just thought and he's like oh well she
knows about us so and she annoys me so
I'm just gonna kill her so yeah it's
just that just confirms my suspicions
that he just kills because he want
because he wants to do it doesn't have
anything to do with what you are yes
doing now their last victim that at
least that they were convicted of and
this is really sad this actually
occurred while police were actively
investigating them like they hadn't
found all the murders they hadn't found
the barrels or anything yet but they
were still investigating them in
relation to all these missing persons
cases this guy was named David Johnson
he was James bliss a kisses stepbrother
now this kid was killed on May 9th 1999
he wasn't gay he wasn't a pedophile yeah
basically bunting just wanted to kill
somebody and and you know he he did like
call him a [ __ ] and stuff like that
but you know he probably called
everybody that because yes one of those
so what ended up happening there was
that you know David Johnson wanted to
buy a computer he was really into
computers
James felicitous was like well come up
to snow town we have all these computers
in this disused bank that we have and
you can buy one off us so he drives the
kid up there to snow town law
I'm into the bank vault and then bunting
and Wagner kill him cut off part of his
flesh take it across the street to a
friend's house and cook it and eat it
and also feed it to their friend who
didn't know that it was a human me so
they were into cannibalism to yeah well
that was the only case that they know
for that they're getting into it was
escalating it was escalating oh it
definitely did because honestly the
first victim Clinton true size he was
basically just bashful
just to just bash with a shovel and
buried right but as the guy got more and
more more there was no more torture
there was warrantless so he was starting
to enjoy it like I said he wasn't even
pretending to really have a reason
anymore it's just I'm just gonna write
whatever so yeah at this point him and
Wagner like we're like yeah let's let's
eat part of him yeah yeah so they kind
of part him and took it across street
Nate and then like I said fed it to a
friend of theirs who didn't know that it
was a person right so and this yeah but
if you were friends with this guy you're
suspicious probably yeah honestly yeah
so yeah and evidently like a lot of
people were scared of this dude because
he was all of these kind of people that
were in his inner circle hmm other than
him hmm seemed like either idiots or
vulnerable easily led pure I think the
saddest case was James bliss a kiss
because you know he was just a kid he
wasn't he hadn't had a father figure so
this guy was like the closest thing to a
father figure and he kind of used that
vulnerability Bunton kind of used that
vulnerability to get this kid to like go
on and like ruling him through fear and
trying to get him to do whatever he
wanted yeah that's a bizarre dude yes so
it seemed like he had that imp like he
targeted people that were on the margins
of society that were weak easily led
like I said and then like would
manipulate them into doing all these
horrible things his intelligence was
normal yeah normal or normal too high if
you know from everything around him
selves with idiots with kind of yeah
that weren't really that smart people
that were kind of take a minute had
problems or you know or were otherwise
weak drug addicts things like that so he
could control control or to kill him off
and worried about it yeah and like I
said David Johnson was there was their
last victim he was the only victim
actually killed in snow town itself the
sad thing
about all of this is that these murders
referred to as the snow town murders
only one of them took place in snow town
none of the victims were from there
none of the killers were from there and
this poor all these poor people that
live in this dinky little farming town
they're like basically now this town
that's all that that's known for and
it's like we get all these tourists
coming here taking pictures themselves
in front of the [ __ ] Bank building
where they found the bodies right
there's like none of this [ __ ] happened
here it's like the only reason that it's
called that is because that's where they
found the bodies and the only reason the
bodies were stored there is because they
thought oh the well the cops are gonna
come get us so it's a stinky town out in
the middle of nowhere where we can stash
stuff and no one will find out about it
yeah so it didn't really there wasn't a
relation to that town so for a while
everybody that lived there were like
maybe we should change the name they
were thinking about changing it grows
town but I don't think they ever got
around to doing that because they just
thought it was such a shame that you
can't even that you said in the whole
country of Australia you say that name
and everybody assumes you're talking
about oh there's no time murders right
and like I said now in 2011 they made a
movie about it that was called snow town
so it's like you know kind of sucks to
live there I guess sucks for them now as
I said at the criminal trial bunting in
Wagner were charged with they were
actually charged with 12 they were
convicted of 11 so they each got 11 life
sentences
there was a 12th victim Susanne Allen
who had lived nearby
she was associated with Ray Davies she
was one of the ones that was found in
buntings former back yard she was buried
back there she was all cut up she was
like in 17 different plastic bags they
had a lot of evidence but they couldn't
conclusively prove that she had been
murdered because bunting said oh well
she just died of a heart attack so we
just cut her up and buried her in the
you know I find that hard to believe
yeah but the jury was kind of deadlocked
on it well like you know all the other
was they had so much overwhelming
evidence from other ones there's like
well there's just not quite as
compelling evidence in this case so they
just didn't get convicted of that but
they got convicted of 11 now also
convicted as I said was James was a cos
he actually pled guilty to four counts
of murder which were the ones that he
was involved in and took a lighter
sentence in exchange for telling them
everything about all the other ones mark
Haden was also
stood trial separately now he was
accused of two counts of murder
including that of his wife I believe and
also of aiding and abetting she was like
helping them cuz he knew about it and he
was helping them cut up the bodies and
stuff like that now they could not the
jury decided that they could not
conclusively prove that he had
participated in the murders that he was
charged with however he did get charged
with aiding and abetting on several
cases and I think he got a 28-year
sentence I believe so yes so these
people are all in prison still some real
winners right this is really one of the
only case in one of the guys on the
documentary this was actually it was on
as a show called crimes that shook
Australia and they were talking about
this called the bodies and the barrels
murders and he was saying this might be
one of the very few cases in the world
ever of a serial killers that not only
had all these people like helping him
out but also kind of this group kind of
ate their own yeah you know what I mean
words like truly like I said only one of
the victims was a stranger right all the
other ones were friends family members
other associates
so it seems bizarre that it took so long
for these crimes to be I guess not
though because if you're killing other
witnesses yeah if you're killing people
you know you're killing family members
that never get reported missing right
because Clinton true size for the first
victim you know he was missing for three
years before anybody reported him
missing
so it's like like I said these are kind
of people on the fringes of society
right now that goes on I know now I'm
kind of worried Ayanna how much of it
cuz that can't be the only time that's
happened you know you kill enough people
you might get away with it especially if
you're in a weird area where you're like
on the fringe of civilization right well
and like i said serial killers have been
knowing that forever it's like you know
argot some of those semi abandoned towns
on the edge of on the edges of you know
- I mean right dead cities like you know
that place where there was a coal fire
coal mine fires underneath the ground oh
yeah abandoned in Pennsylvania yeah well
you can still drive in there and they're
the kind of little areas around there
yeah so weird you knows what goes on in
places like that right
because who would ever know would ever
know and particularly like I said in a
case like this where all of these people
are neighbors and know of each other
and it's like if you know too much then
they just bump you off right it would be
happening between just a very small
number of people for maybe only a few
years until there was like well maybe
only one or two of them left that one
doesn't tell on himself yeah and I mean
honestly it happened yeah and as I said
I'd you know I don't know particularly
the ones that were later killed yeah you
know it's it's only a couple of people's
words that oh these this person helped
with this murderer this person knew
about the murders like did Elizabeth
Hayden know about the murders before she
got killed who knows she's dead we know
that you know in the 1800's early
nineteen hundred's discussed stuff kind
of happened you know in Townsend was
never reported right yeah no but in the
modern era it's hard to know and like I
said I think that it's sad because like
really the only reason that this whole
horrible web of crime came to light was
because Elizabeth Hayden disappeared now
her husband didn't report her but her
brother did yeah and that kind of
stemmed and then it kind of tied in with
these other two cold cases that they
just happened to pull this cold case
there's like oh let's re-examine this
because we don't have anything you know
we're not busy right now so let's pull
some cold cases and they happen to pull
this one that was related so and then it
kind of uncovered this whole seedy
underbelly of like all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
that was going on yeah and it's like
kind of reminds me that I read that was
going on in Russia around the late 1800s
Early 1900s I think there was some
people think they were called cool acts
yeah I think they live up in the
mountains they're wearing fur
yeah and evidently the Soviet
authorities would catch him every now
and then where they were cannibalizing
members of their own family up and
helping those log cabins punishing them
for cannibalism weird they found like a
head they'd go into those uh log cabins
and find heads you know heads of people
that they had eaten and I would just
keep the heads I guess it again snowed
in or something I don't know exertion
I'm gonna look more into it they were
getting hungry up in there and eating
each other
yeah
yeah yeah yeah like these [ __ ]
yeah nasty ass [ __ ] relax but
you know yeah that's like I don't know
so anyway this case has been requested a
whole bunch of times I have not actually
seen I wanted to see the movie snow town
and like I said a couple days ago I was
like oh it was on Netflix I'm gonna go
watch it and now it's gone yeah I
actually don't like seeing that kind of
stuff well I wanted to see it just for
research purposes even though like I
said I've heard and if you've seen it
please let me know I've heard that it's
a very very unpleasant watch which like
I said I can imagine that it probably
III actually saw it compared to Henry
portrait of a serial killer oh I don't
like that also a very unpleasant much
it's a great movie oh yeah I'm not
saying that's a great movie but it's not
one that I don't I don't think yeah I
think that's a long time ago right after
it came out and I remember being
convinced that I was almost seeing
something that was free that's what was
disturbing about to see it it's like
yeah I think I'm gonna like yeah have a
bleach even though for the more fun more
I found out about those two guys I think
they lied about almost well yeah I think
they did make up a lot of that scene I
do think they killed people but I know
that they shot some guys in again and
they shot a guy in a gas station that's
yeah and I think they were suspected at
a couple of other ones but I think they
were just mostly a confession machines
yeah cuz didn't they confess like a
hundred man they confess myself that was
later on disproven that they did that
they didn't do they know the guy did it
they just would get out of prison if
they confessed for stuff they didn't
want to be out of prison really yeah
they liked it in there I guess I'll yeah
some people are weird like that
well there were no buddies yeah you know
if when you look at him you hear I'm
talking you're like hey you don't belong
it's a semi that kind of happens with a
lot and I and I think it definitely
happened in the case of this [ __ ]
loser here um bunting who like I said
you know some of the other ones he was
involved or their artwork also lowlifes
yeah but he seemed to be kind of the
instigator and he seemed to get off on
you know I'm Batman I'm going around
like killing pedophiles and gay people
yeah we're all for all of you for the
good of society yeah yeah all right so
anyway hope you in well I don't want to
say enjoyed because blessed Suffolk none
of our shits pleasant topic sorry about
that you guys but yeah so I hope you
enjoyed episode
1:02 remember if you like the show to
like share subscribe share with all your
friends on all your social media it
really helps us out a lot if you'd like
to financially support the show you can
go to our patreon page at patreon.com
slash thirteen o'clock or you can go to
our blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
WordPress com and there's link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to make a one-time donation also
check out our dazzling calm slash 13
o'clock we have several cool t-shirts
and a tote bag that you may purchase if
you desire also check out our latest
movie review which was David
Cronenberg's first feature film shivers
from 1975 so go check that out if you
haven't already
Roberta tune into our regular shows
every Tuesday and our movie reviews
every Friday and we will see you next
time bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]